[Music]
we're taking you
inside kanye west's album release party
devil on my shoulders push them off my
sleeve
kanye celebrated the release of his 10th
studio album
donda named after his late mother and
get this
kim kardashian and their kids were all
in attendance at the atlanta event
[Music]
at the end of the day life is about
being happy i know god
is all in us it was an
emotional night kanye dropping to his
knees during
this track love unconditionally five
months after kim
filed for divorce
[Music]
does he come to you before and say lick
wifey i'm gonna put this song out and
get your approval beforehand do you guys
do that yet yes it's really fun to see
just days ago kim and kanye looked to be
getting along
reuniting with the kids at an art museum
in san francisco a source told et
quote it was clear that kim and kanye
still have love for each other
but more so in a co-parenting sense the
source added quote
it was a genuine sweet moment for the
family where they were able to relax
in a public setting without being
disrupted i feel like we are so blessed
to have
the best support system and the best
family to
really just support each other no matter
what we're going through
someone else who surprisingly showed up
at the album release event
jay-z so many felonies
[Music]
the pair is making music together once
again jay-z appears on kanye's song
called
guess who's going to jail tonight
[Music]
this might be
fans are hoping this means a follow-up
to their collab album
watch the throne you are now watching
the throne
don't let me get in my zone i mean it
was just fun to go in and vibe out not
worry about
what was happening on radio or how
successful the song would be
just just do something for my heart
[Music]
[Applause]